[Musique]
léo 17 ans motards dans l'âme roule pour
leurs enfants 50 centimètres cubes
il habite dans ta un mot à 10 km de
louhans et depuis ses 14 ans sont deux
roues lui a tout simplement changé la
vie avant c'était sms à papa-maman où on
prenait nos paires de chaussures on
allait à pied où on prenait le vélo tout
simplement pour se déplacer c'est
vraiment un sentiment de liberté
d'autonomie
voir aller là où je veux quand je veux
ça a vraiment un aspect très pratique
dans le bourg en tout cas surtout qu'on
n'est pas très bien servi
vos transports en commun pour les eaux
la moto c'est matin midi et soir pour
les loisirs mais surtout pour se rendre
sur son lieu d'apprentissage un garage
spécialisé dans les cyclomoteurs ou de
forme depuis maintenant deux ans une
façon d'allier passion et travail
là on va la télé clie pour son maître
d'apprentissage la vie sera un peu
difficile en bresse pour la plupart des
jeunes sans les deux roues on est une
région où c'est assez étendu les
distances sont grandes certains jeunes
ont besoin de ces petits véhicules qui
leur permettent de se déplacer de chez
eux jusque l'école leur lieu de travail
leur lieu de retrouvailles aussi
visiblement à louhans le marché du deux
roues se porte bien
pas moins de trois revendeurs
spécialisés dans les cyclomoteurs et un
autre dans la moto pour une commune de
6300 habitants dans cette ville à la
campagne tous les jeunes n'ont pas
forcément les moyens de s'acheter une
robe ou un scooter ya rien de
particulier et démarre bien le matin 5
en période de froid c'est toujours
compliqué scooters voitures et même vélo
depuis 2009 mission mobilité permet aux
jeunes et aux moins jeunes d'avoir un
moyen de transport individuel pour aller
travailler
geci 19 ans habite à louhans et à
trouver du travail à cuiseaux ce scooter
loup et 15 euros par semaine est pour
lui un vrai coup de pouce au niveau de
l'essence on n'a pas forcément de bus
pas forcément de
personne qui peut nous emmener au
travail donc le temps de passer mon
permis pour moi ça m'aide beaucoup
à la campagne on le voit bien les
transports en commun ont leurs limites
travail études ou loisirs pour les
jeunes le cyclo reste un allié
indispensable